ATTACK SPECIALLY BUT THE PUCKS
DOWN SLOWS IT DOWN
AND START FOR JAKE AND A
LOCKING IN HERE IS USED  AND H
THEM OUT OF THEIR OWN AND PUT I
HIS OWN THAT
>> FOR THE COMOMTHE SUPPORT CAU
TO GET TURUR UNIT.
NEXT LEVEL LOOK THERE IN THE
LILI A QUICK
WRAPAROUND ATTEMPT.
>> GOOD JOB BY THE IN
THE CHIP IT
AND THAT THAT WASASCHANCE
PRETTY GOOD PLAY THEREBY LADEDE
MEKENZIE BLACK BLOODLUST TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT JAKE GET THERE CUP
ASSISTANT IN NEW YORK.THAT PARK
BEMSTROM BUT HAS ITS HEAD UP ON
THE BLUE LINE AND MADE A SOLID
LUCKCKWILL DROP AT THEIR.
INTENT YOU PUTGET HOW THEY TURN
THE OOKS FROM HER
MINSKY WHO IS RIGHT THERE TOP
BLUE JACKETS AND THAT'S ROSLOVI
UP ON THE PLAY.
>> COVER NAMESTNIKOV ABLE TO
KEEP IT IN WITH A VACUUM.OVER A.
INDEED A 44 KE THAT AN OFFENSE
ZONE DRAW FOR THE SHOT REVERSE
SCRAMBLE THERE AND IT'S COVERED
NOT